[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds of challengers not one
winner we don't make mistakes never have
never will will tonight a fan named
David says he thinks he caught a mistake
he says it happened during a recent
monologue I think I found a mistake on
your show during the opening monologue
you did that that cool Michael Jackson
moonwalk across the screen like this but
then shortly afterwards you did your
classic canoe [ __ ] but when you turn
back to face the audience
you pulled the or across the front of
you
Conan that's not how water works if you
want to turn the boat you have to move
the oar in the opposite direction even I
know that and I'm gay
[Music]
well no offense David but just because
you're gay doesn't mean you're not wrong
I was paddling correctly here to back me
up is paddling expert and gay icon
George Takei
[Applause]
[Applause]
David my dear misguided friend I'm
afraid you don't understand the basic
principles of nature you see water works
differently for straight people
that's because water itself is gay we
wouldn't have raindrops or oceans if
water didn't like to bind to itself
[Laughter]
the fact is most things in nature are
gays air is gay rocks are gay the North
Pole and South Pole are gay they only
repel each other because they're in
denial but others like Conan are not gay
so naturally they interact differently
with that which is gay
Conan paddled correctly David for a
straight person so please put aside your
heterophobia for just a moment and
accept conan for who he is
[Applause]
chowin still stands if you think you've
spotted an error on our show reported
team koco.com /a high fund an error we
will sort it out right here on the air
let's see if you've got what it takes
jump me out of the maestro